olá a todos o pessoal daqui quem fala é
o dark sejam muito bem vindos de mais um
vídeo e os estragos e que vai virar e 7
fredes 2 e hoje nós estamos aqui para
julgar essa está noite que é
oficialmente a última noite do fado
night at freddy's 2
eu sei que a questão na equipe mas
oficialmente esta é a última noite é
mais complicada mais assustadora por
isso vai borrar muito pessoal muito bem
que o jato mais ou menos habituado ao
chute porque na quinta noite fiquei
cerca de 1 hora e meia duas a tentar
passar a quinta noite e esta sexta à
noite ainda vai levar mais tempo a ser o
pessoal se conseguir passar esta noite
vai ser o são porque esta não ter muito
complicada mesmo esse algo que você já
conseguiu passar do jogo já consegui
passar esta noite e extermina idioma e
nos comentários opel saber quantos de
vocês já conseguiram passar o jogo eu
agora vou ter que ficar aqui mais no
palhaço porque ele é muito rápido agora
eu não sei se o tempo é o mesmo mas eu
tenho a impressão que o palhaço em cada
noite passa fica mais rápido vai contar
exatamente os a raposa já aparecem em
primeiro está um pouco previsível né
ok a orientar dentro da ventilação acho
que o zé do balão calma tem que ir
embora
o fred que muitas vezes não têm
consciência que vou ficar aqui muitas
horas a jogar isto porque eu fiquei 1
hora e meia noite cinco imagine oq meu
cai tranquilo fred equipe
gogo amigos não faça mal a calma palhaço
é uma da manhã ainda palhaço não pode
seguir esta hora ainda tem calma contigo
cai eu acho que a oposição entrou na
ventilação da direita
o gado espera lá duas da manhã o que é
pessoal
são duas da manhã consegui aguentar até
às duas da manhã na sexta à noite o
balão zero bala daqui também
calma deixamos pra que você vai embora
hoje caraças
ok ok ok ok vai conseguir aguentar até
que as duas da manhã
foi isso uma da manhã caiana marca
exatamente star que está calma e não sei
se ela vai saltar em cima eu acho que o
rap e funk e é o pessoal é esse mesmo de
começar a usar a marca muito festa assim
ó cae está tranqüilo deixem ver se há ou
não que não mascara nada tranquilo mas
nada tranqüilo e começar a jogar assim
está tudo tranqüilo por aqui pessoal
vou ter que tomar muita atenção e fred
meu balão não está aqui câmara
exatamente o que eu acho que ser rápido
ok mas nós estômago e também pessoal da
companhia já peguei o jeito agora é só
aguentar até às seis da manhã
assim a foi lento foi então vamos saltar
eu fui lento
eu sabia eu sabia eu fui lá eu fui lento
opep só apanha estratégia já apanhei
mais ou menos o ritmo por isso eu vou
começar agora eu jogar assim mas tem que
ter mais atenção também fazer algo como
isto e skol exatamente só quem tem que
ser mesmo muito rápido e tranqüilo meta
máscara e acho que é só apanhar o jeito
é só apanhar jeito só é só apanhar foco
em direito também uma da manhã eu acho
que o capítulo
eu acho que fui rápido acho que o rápido
mas só quem gosta está muito complicado
aí o palhaço palhaço anão já foi já fui
eu vá apanhar eu vá apanhar para o
palácio para apanhar o advogado do
jogador galgado quase morri agora meu
quase morri agora é pessoal que foi
muito boa mesmo
amanhã 30 mas que é muito rápido uma da
manhã
na primeira tentativa eu consegui chegar
até as duas mãos
agora já não consigo passada uma faca
agora foi muito lento da manhã analisar
raposa ii foi lento foi lento foi lento
foi nem precisa ser mais rápido mas anda
ok pessoal aos poucos e poucos vou
conseguindo aos poucos e poucos vou
conseguindo
ok ae isso é isso mesmo daqui stage vem
caindo da manhã
se eu conseguir passar para 3 é muito
bom já só isso agora foi rápida e os é
uma parceria da mentira tio meu que o
fred vai sofrer é tranquilo são três da
manhã pessoal são três da manhã faltam
mais três horas e eu consegui isto o
ataque os raposas calma eu tô a vida
cara isso no meu caso embora nas fui
rápido fui rápido foi capitu é que nem
vai mexer pato foi rápido
ok a raposa espera patrimônio raposas
embora acho eu né
aí está aqui ele entrou aqui ela entrou
aqui eu vou morrer eu vou morrer só vou
morrer
ok ok ok y consegui aguentar até às três
da manhã que já não é nada é nada mau
eu vou ter com a vitória de felipe mas
eu vou ter que uma vitória não terá mais
que cada vez mais rápido
por isso é preciso prestar atenção e
beber já que eu vou aí pessoal está
muito complicado mesmo eu já fui buscar
um café de bebida energética tudo e mais
alguma coisa para conseguir concentrar
nisto mas nada nada porque esta noite é
muito complicada mesmo quando eu
consegui passar isso ao sério eu vou
saltar pela casa toda
tudo num gritar por e pítons é
a ganassi nenhum quatro da manhã quatro
da manhã
só que é vai deixar pato que usava
roupas tamanho
a faca
não no mattos filho da mãe sim tamanha
cinco da manhã é caraças cinco da manhã
às cinco da manhã
canso só ó
cinco da manhã
o único emprego e outra vez o governo
frente outra vez meu já possui planta
verde mas ok go de falar passar parte da
manhã é meu a calma calma para lá para
lá de chover só quando eu receber um
cheque o planeta consegue passar aí sim
encarar os custos e conseguir um curso
de passar esta noite eu fiquei muito
tempo no meio da portaria tem muita
coisa pra aguentar e tineu 20 euros tudo
bem que nos dá muita coisa pessoal
conseguir passar faz manchete fredes e
agora tenho que cantar um funk maitan
que são 28 20 e 23 10 vá ainda não
acredito meu eu passaria fãs à noite nem
o cérebro salto mesmo muito contente
obrigado por tudo o nosso apoio até
agora é eu vou preparar um vídeo
especial ou talvez uma web stream presta
questão night 2010 mas deixou o pessoal
deixa um vasto leque favorito fickman
contar com esse vosso mega ultra apoio
ontem foi continuamente
eu quero agradecer o imenso pessoal
porque o canal está a subir muito
mesmo você tem apoiado muito mas mesmo
muito então é isso pessoal espero que
vocês gostem deste vídeo fique bem e até
a próxima